I wouldn't say just our game just that
the game itself is always gonna be
special to me and symbol is that
adding 101
ah no one I don't really care to play I
don't really care to see don't wanna win
that doesn't really show much basketball
is a team sport and that's that
what do you say realm
I mean a lot I mean as it pertains to
Kobe and his family and the tragedy
there's a lot of things that I like to
keep to myself and keep between myself
and him and and respect for his family
i'ma keep that to myself
No
our gift means uh I believe everybody
been blessed with the talent and I
believe God has blessed everyone to
honor each and every one of their gifts
and that's kind of where I got the name
from thanks brother
hold on wait wait somebody gotta listen
somebody answer a question over here
oh yeah definitely man Jane's been
teammates all-star game is maybe the
first time so I think it's it's it's
exciting it's something that we can
cherish and look forward to and I'm
happy to to experience it it's been
great
we're moving in the right direction I'm
happy where we are I'm happy where we
were headed
each game and throughout each season you
find ways to be able to make your
teammates better and found ways to be
able to sacrifice certain parts of your
game and that's definitely normal which
in which is following me
I play all positions I do whatever it is
for me to do on a court to help us win
and that's what I do
mitral position yes I'm a point guard I
play point guard a lot of people like to
take that away from it because of the
things I do but I am a point guard now
and I'd like to dominate that position
and that is my natural position I just
try to find ways to make an impact
obviously with this style of playing
different guys on the floor allows
people to have the GAR one-on-one to be
and have the guard and a lot of space
which is to my advantage so set again
see internally we don't think it's small
ball we just playing our personnel and
go and compete and that's it
[Applause]
I can't I can't hear y'all questions
[Applause]
I can't we warmer there
okay
I'm not sure man that's a lot of
obviously a lot of great and amazing
players that plays this game and that we
look forward to playing with so I'm not
sure I'm not sure I mean Oklahoma is a
great city and a great place to be but
with definitely you'll need more hotels
and more venues and more things that
have an officer getting there I'm not
sure
[Applause]